strong winds are blowing again in
Southern California making it harder for
firefighters to control the deadly
Woolsey fire it's destroyed an estimated
four hundred and thirty five buildings
west of Los Angeles and burned more than
93 thousand acres that is an area that
is bigger than Detroit that fire has
killed two people
Jamie yuccas is in Malibu which is still
under a mandatory evacuation order Jamie
good morning good morning it seems like
this that have homeowners across
Southern California very nervous about
the weather conditions the Woolsey fire
is 30% contained but firefighters say
the threat is far from over
gusty Santa Ana winds continue to cause
flare-ups overnight forcing firefighters
to move from spot fire to spot fire some
two hundred thousand people remain under
mandatory evacuation orders dry
vegetation low humidity and mountainous
geography are making it hard for crews
to get the upper hand here yesterday we
spoke with Cal Fire Battalion Chief
Lucas Spellman what started this fire
most people that's the number one
question people have is what caused the
Cystic why yet sometimes it takes weeks
and even once to actually put all that
together utility company Southern
California Edison says that it had an
outage just two minutes before the fire
started on Thursday now if they're held
responsible they could pass the cost on
to customers that's because of a new
state law that allows lawsuits and
damage caused to be passed on to
customers so that the utility company
doesn't go bankrupt
bianna it's unbelievable you think of
the cost the human cost and of course
the cost for these first responders that
are racing to the scene it is
unbelievable to think that this is our
new normal there